todos os seus limites é o desafio que eu
vos cria por hoje e por todos aqueles
que ousarem aceitar o meu desafio
através de uma ferramenta para ajudar a
concretizar os nossos grandes projetos
nossos sonhos
isto que eu sei que todos vocês em algum
momento da vossa vida pararam pra pensar
ah eu gostava tanto de más mas há sempre
um mas na nossa vida que o fundo é um
limitante um obstáculo que nos impede de
nós iremos aonde nós queremos diziam nós
queremos chegar
na realidade nós vivemos com esses
limites que o som dos impostos
a onda nossa face do crescimento pela
sociedade
pelo meio o nome que nós vivemos pela
nossa educação
então a nossa personalidade da nossa
capacidade física ea verdade é que nós
nem sequer nos questionamos e eu tal
como vocês vivem muitos anos muitos
partilhada pelos meus limites muito
limitava e um dia eu questionei porque
não tirar a carta de mota eu lembro de
andar na cidade e as pessoas pararem no
chimarródromo teve uma conversa comigo
fato não havia raparigas a conduzir moto
nesta altura e depois mais tarde porque
não fazer uma corrida nos exames
organizados todos para fazer uma corrida
todo-o-terreno desafiaram pelo qual eu
achava que não tinha condições de ensino
e salvos de química pensar será que eu
sou capaz e lá fui eu e até hoje
continue sempre fazer todas as coisas em
um disco aquela ideia louca de fazer o
dakar do motor
imaginem em cima de uma moto honda
equipada por 0 fora e aquela imagem fez
tantos sentidos que foi ter com os jogos
inclusive acho que tu achas que eu fizer
o dakar mota
qual foi a resposta de altar louca nem
penso disse isso na prática essa é uma
professora com alguns bonfim participar
em 4 e termina em 2 e quando o ciclo das
motas começou a chegar ao fim
a ew conceito em cidade de abandonar a
competição não cria um lado mas tinha
que pôr outro e não é muito tempo a
tomar essa decisão em um momento em que
eu tomei a decisão de abandonar a
competição eu senti me levo ela fique
bem disposta e de repente comigo a
pensar assim
espera aí porque não faço caminhão nunca
uma mulher fez nada na vida vai ser mais
difícil do que aquilo que eu fiz nota
imaginem um caminhão saltar as dunas
aquela imagem fez tanto sentido para mim
que ainda hoje continua a fazer corridas
caminhão
ao longo da minha vida destes vários
projetos longos que não tem sucesso
naturalmente o volt que eu consegui ser
bem sucedida e reparei que de facto
existe um método conhecido como réus
todos e esse é que eu queria trazer hoje
aqui pra vocês que eu acho que é uma
ferramenta de sucesso vocês podem
utilizar as vossas nos vossos projectos
vários quatro passos principais quais
são meus primeiros todos sonhar mas
falta um sonho grande ambicioso difícil
realizar o foi uma coisinha colina fácil
concretizar qualquer um faz
não tem sequer o estatuto sony segundo
passo objetivaram seja tornar e sony é
algo concreto algo que eu possa é
trabalhar algo que eu possa concretizar
sem passo a acreditar seriamente se
vocês virem um só segundo que seja vocês
não vocês nunca realizar e finalmente o
último elemento desenvolvidos exatamente
trabalhar embora algum destes aspectos
faça transpirar mais do que outros
assuntos igualmente importantes vocês
minimizar em deus você já não vão
consistir aonde querem chegar
sentindo agora o que de mais sobre o que
um deus que se eles não querem mais cada
um deus sonhar quando falo da palavra
sim eu posso referir várias palavras
tais como ambicionar pensar visualizá
imaginar diz já sentir todas elas são
igualmente importante porque porque não
basta a gente ter uma ideia genial uma
idéia fantástica e por um telão na
cabeça se é um sonho que eu quero
realizar um tem que viver esse sonho eu
tenho que dedicar alguns minutos da
minha vida alguns segundos algum tempo é
a senhora realmente é visualizar a
imaginar como frau altura o momento em
que eu atingir um objetivo como é que
vão ser as circunstâncias o que eu vou
sentir nesse momento deixar que eu
aquela alegria de realizar o vosso a
vossa meta de atingir o nosso objetivo
incentivar a sentirem se contente
deixarem construir só fica ganhava sua
auto é isso que vocês têm que fazer
vocês tem que visualizar e por quê por
quê
esta capacidade de visualizar no fundo
ela que nos cria as oportunidades que
nós precisamos concretizar nosso sangue
por nós temos conosco uma máquina
fantástica que é o nosso cérebro é um um
fosse que nós temos que nos ajuda
a concretizar todos os nossos objetivos
de tudo o que nós queremos
dizem os especialistas que nós temos um
cérebro que é conscientes que pensa que
raciocina que julga que tomar decisões e
temos um cervo inconsciente que não
pensa que não decidi que não julga que
não calcula que tem uma forma de
trabalhar que nós não compreendemos mas
que o grande observador do cérebro coxim
se eu falar vai ver que o que nós
queremos cumprir as nossas ordens das
nossas instituições em cumprir os nossos
designers e vocês podem achar que
conquistei muito estranho mas eu postar
se em dois exemplos simples por exemplo
se eu conseguir caminhar daqui paulo
enquanto conversa com vocês eu posso
fazer ou sem pensar um microssegundo
qual é um músculo da perna que eu tenho
comprimir e qual é o estilo que eu tenho
claro como comprimir por simplesmente o
caminho aí as coisas processos em que
tome consciência delas na mesma forma se
eu quiser procurar alguém no meio de uma
multidão se eu pensar nessa pessoa que
me concentrar nessas eu consegui
encontrá la no chão pensar numa panela
anúncio quando eu nunca mais vou
encontrar atualmente e portanto esta
capacidade nós vivermos um projeto nós
queremos concretizar no futuro no
presente faz coisas fantásticas
eu posso contar uma história eu tive um
dia fazer corridas caminhão mas começou
a briga lógica e bom senso e achei que
era razoável seu primeiro fizesse
corridas carro então se fazer uma ou
duas corridas carro fazer o dakar carro
primeira final em um carro uma empresa
belga e conseguir fazer essa 12 corridas
e certa altura aconteceu a meio do ano
a minha jogadora vai ter comigo e disse
mancini a estabilizar perto é afinal eu
não posso fazer o placar contigo porque
enfim vou ficar sem férias não gravar a
diferença sozinho com clientes a pessoa
a quem eu tinha alugado no cartunista
fica se que existia foi postado um vídeo
fiquei sem carro
entretanto não conseguia dinheiro para
fazer o placar e quando eu conheci
a e o círio rádio portalegre coisa que
eu nunca faço ou participar nas corridas
ou ficar em casa e na que lances e
curiosamente acaba por encontrar lá a
pessoa que julgava espaço nos seus
caminhões provaram toda mota os pneus
das peças que fosse preciso
o espanhol e os jogos e brincadeiras
proibições elizabeth já que a ministra
tirou a carta de pesados e eu olho pra
mim muito sério mesmo assim a é então
vou fazer uma proposta e fez uma
proposta de fazer o dakar caminhão com o
mesmo com os que eu fazia de moto e
vocês dizem que o fato de ser uma
coincidência é fantástica e eu digo
assim se calhar não é só uma
coincidência
existem de facto muitas coincidências
fantásticas e eu gosto de contar várias
não posso não quero e não posso
nós podemos contar várias coincidências
fantásticas que acontece que nós criamos
muito e atingir um objetivo e houve um
sikh atrair psicoterapeuta suíço nunca
nunca abdicou de cobrando parte da sua
vida a estudar este nome
ah e eu criou até uma teoria que chamou
dívida sincronicidade e por cinco
necessidade de explicar vaqueiro com
dois ou mais acontecimentos existiam
estando com os finados um culto mas não
uma relação de causa e efeito
e você dizia sim de fato a ser
fantástico mas como é que se explica não
sair e também novos a companhia perderem
tempo a tentar perceber como tempo como
eu tentei acima tudo meu desafio é
experimentar em te ver o que acontece
o outro passo o objetivo objetivo no
fundo sinhá era um corpo voava um vocês
fizessem objetivo funcionar assim que
tem como mostrava é eu que os conduz na
direção que vocês querem realmente pra
isso você tem que saber formular muito
bem esse objetivo não é como que maneira
você tem que ter um objetivo muito
específico que diga exatamente aquilo
que vocês querem
tem que ser realista se eu disser que
este verão quer passar férias na lua e
ganhar um objetivo não é realista eu
nunca mais vou conseguir realizar o que
tem que ser orientar passam tem que
dizer que vocês têm que fazer para
conseguir atingir esse objetivo
meu sonho é terminar o dakar motos
notícia tenha treinado moto
treinar fisicamente em organizar uma
série de coisas logística arranjar
patrocínios etc
é tem que ser mensurável vocês têm que
ter noção se estão ou não aproximar é do
vosso objetivo é e tem que ser limitado
no tempo não basta dizer eu quero isto
no dia de são nunca por sinal nunca mais
se vai realizar naturalmente acreditar
bom acreditar eu acho que o combustível
do vosso projecto realmente quando vocês
acreditam em vocês conseguem suportar
todas as contrariedades todas as
dificuldades todos os obstáculos nada
vos derruba vocês vão direitinhos vocês
querem
onde vocês querem é uma energia fabulosa
que vem de dentro é que depende só de
vocês mas que nos dá uma força e se
torne invencíveis e não há nada que nos
faça para e uma altura da minha vida que
eu nem vou ler muitos livros sobre estes
temas
lembro de um livro do mais moraes o
selecionador harry ontem dizia uma frase
pra mim fazia todos em que dizia querer
é poder
estou a frase toda a gente conhece o
agente da família dela com ela mas crê é
vencer crê no sentido de aproveitar com
nós acreditamos nós vamos até onde
queremos ir visitar frontin a o último
aspecto que o show é que vocês tenham
que fazer é fato trabalhar trabalhar
trabalhar trabalhar sem limites até não
poder mais
mas de fato trabalhar ganhar temos que
rentabilizar a nossa energia trabalhar
com muita qualidade sabe planear saber
organizar considerar o fator tempo e
isso é muito importante estes fatores
estes quatro e aumente o vice quem são
os pilares do sucesso nos permita ir até
um de vocês quiserem visitar e vocês
dizem já se a isso é muito bonito pois é
mas ao limite e eu digo assim o fato ao
limite mas nunca então nós pensamos
todos podem dar
eu fiz 200 quilômetros do rally do mídia
como a clavícula partida e mota pesava
200 quilos e hoje os cientistas já
poderão provar que em situação um dos
sobreviventes da pessoa está em causa é
o nosso cérebro é capaz inclusive de
anular a sensação de dor e eu criamos
contar também uma outra história é que
eu vi foi um ano um ano no rali a pensar
que não tinha condições de continuar me
sentia muito mal sente envergonhada em
itália ponte realizado o projeto
realizar o meu sonho que era terminar o
dakar mota e não conseguir avançar para
frente já não ter que ficar sempre mais
longe e claro eu comecei a acreditar que
constantemente eu lembro levantar a moto
ainda não tenha largado em brejão
completamente e já estava a cair outra
vez
ah e pra defender no meio do percurso é
eu decidi deixar os trilhos mais
marcados por zona mais dura mas tornará
mais fácil e nunca certa altura numa e
dos faróis da mota eo vinho da casa
cargos vagos típicos do deserto que os
troncos gross que as linhas muito
fininhas e reparei que o fato estava na
direção burgos e naturalmente de que
tenha um diálogo robusto mas com vocês
devem calcular eu não fiz nada para
desviar do robusto e certa altura
realmente como soluções urgentes e de
quem entrava no anterior gosto
vocês acham que eu trabalho trazer coisa
nenhuma em faixa em burgos com toda a
força
mas na realidade como eu não ia muito
depressa acabei por ficar pendurada num
arbusto a moto a imposição do cavalo eo
assentado em cima das pernas penduradas
e um rapaz que veio atrás de mim para
mota e desata a rir à gargalhada em rio
até ficar satisfeito e por estar
satisfeito me perguntando assim
elizabeth que eu to jo eu acho nem quer
ainda estava lá sentado em cima da moto
que as pernas penduradas por bastar
simplesmente dar um jeitinho o corpo
utilizar pôr o pé no chão
enchi kaká baixo e só podemos dizer que
de fato atingir os meus limites
já não tenho a minha cabeça funcionava
perfeitamente mas o meu corpo já não
tinha condições de cumprir as instruções
que lhes dava portanto eu tinha de fato
ultrapassado os limites dos limites e
tinha ido muito mais longe do que aquilo
que eu pensava que era possível ler
macho tvs aceite os meus limites se
tivesse não não sou capaz mais a partir
de agora vou entrar em situação
preocupante e não tinha mais uma vez
terminado o placar porque de todos os
que fiz quatro só consegui terminar 2
portanto fazendo uma pequena simples
vocês têm aqui uma ferramenta que os
pode ser muito útil para você realizar
em qualquer projeto vocês queiram se
vocês considerarem sonhar é o motor do
nosso projeto e o objeto de fato é
aquela pista que nos leva até onde vocês
quiserem chegar disse que o fato nós
acreditarmos é que a energia famosa onde
permite desfrutar tudo e mais alguma
coisa e fazer tudo e mais alguma coisa é
o trabalho
no fundo é aquelas peças em instrutor
vocês não vêm mas que estão lá dentro
todo o trabalho milimetricamente que
conseguem pôr voz carro a funcionar
não há dúvida que para compor qualquer
projeto é vocês porém também vós carro a
funcionar vocês têm que dar a ignição é
e da ignição não é nada mais nada menos
do policiamento questionar será que eu
sou capaz de não aceitarem os limites
avançarem as mangas e começar a
trabalhar porque está obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]